على الجانب الغربي والشمالي الغربي
لاوكرانيا وتحديدا على حدودها مع بولندا
وبيلاروسيا تمت قلق وحشد لقوات اضافيه
اشار اليه وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو
بالقرب من حدود دوله الاتحاد يتمركز تجمع
من القوات يضم حوالي 360 الف عسكري
وثمانيه الاف مصفحه وسته الاف منظومه
مدفعيه وقاذفه الغام عدد افراد تشكيلات
الدول غير الاقليميه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
ارتفع بنسبه اثنين ونصف منذ فبراير من
العام الماضي وتجاوز 30 الف شخص المخاطر
الحاليه ترتبط بعسكره بولندا التي اصبحت
الاداه الرئيسيه لسياسه الولايات المتحده
المناهضه لروسيا
تصريحاتو تاتي بينما وافقت وزاره الدفاع
البولنديه على ارسال قوات اضافيه الى
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا خطوه تاتي بعد ظهور
مقاتلين لمجموعه فاجنر قرب الحدود وقراته
وارسو اشاره غير مباشره لها وللجناح
الشرقي
وليس بعيدا اعلنت حكومه لاتفيا تعزيز
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا بسبب مقاله انها
مخاطر امنيه
ذاك على الحدود لكن على الجبهات تستمر
المعارك هنا دخان انفجار في منطقه
شمال الشرقي مقاطعه موسكو قوته فتحت مجال
تكهنات عن اسبابه خصوصا وان موسكوبات ضمن
بنك اهداف مسيرات اوكرانيه في المده
الاخيره تسارع خدمه الطوارئ الروسيه لتوضح
بانهم انفجار لمستودع للالعاب الناريه
تسبب بدوره في انفجار مصنع لمعدات تصوير
ومراقبه واجهزه طبيه ومخبريه لكن في مكان
اخر كانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعلن احباط
محاوله اوكرانيه لتنفيذ هجوم بطائرتين
مسيرتين على العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها
اسقطتهما انظمه الدفاع الجوي الاولى في
منطقه
والاخرى قرب الطريق منسك السريع على
الجبهات اكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
مواصلته هجومها على ثلاثه محاور
فيولوجيا وتنفيذ غاره على مواقع للقوه
الروسيه في هذه الجبهات في الايمان
بدنياتك تحدثت دفاع روسيه عن صدها هجمات
للجيش الاوكراني كما هجمت بالمروحيه مواقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه ومراكز قياده ومراقبه
قالت القوه الروسيه انها السيطره على
مواقع كانت للقوات الاوكرانيه وتصدت
لهجمات اوكرانيه عده على مواقعه على هذا
المحور محور زابولوجيا بدا ملتهبا في
الايام الاخيره هذه صور نشرت الدفاع
الروسيه قالت انها لمسيرات روسيه تهاجم
مواقع اوكرانيا واخرى لمدفعيتها وهي
تستهدف تحركا لمجموعات من القوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه رابوتينا
كما نشرت صورا لهجوم بمروحيه عسكريه قلت
انه استهدف مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه ليمان
الروايه الاوكرانيه بالمقابل تحدثت عن
ثلاث جبهات صدت فيها هجمات روسيه في بخموت
وبريديانسك ورسخ التقدمها في بعض المحاور